et pour en parler nous recevons paul
thompson vice-président du parti
conservateur à paris bonjour monsieur
thomson merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors est ce qu'aujourd'hui
le royaume uni cherche des partenaires
en asie le japon c'est un partenariat
commercial important
il ya déjà des rapports importants entre
le royaume-uni et le japon
le japon est investi pour un mini dans
le secteur financier dans le secteur de
l'automobile est également dans le
secteur de la de la presse le final
photonique est un journal prestigieux à
londres appartient au groupe
nikai qui est un groupe dominant au
japon dans les milieux des affaires et
donc il ya déjà eu des rapports sont
déjà importants mais ils souhaitaient
les développer encore pourquoi justement
cherché
des partenariats en asie compte on est
proche de l'europe même si on a quitté
l'europe
il ne s'agit pas de choix binaire
l'europe et à l'asie où l'asie et pas
par la stratégie commerciale du
gouvernement britannique consiste à dire
que il est important d'entretenir les
rapports économiques très importants
avec l'europe mais pas au détriment du
développement des rapports avec d'autres
parties du monde l'asie l'amérique du
nord aussi à est aussi l'inde et il est
rappelé dans les débats sur ces
questions que le taux de croissance par
exemple est nettement plus élevée en
asie en europe
ça ne veut pas dire qu'il vous plaît
commencé avec l'homme l'idée ce qui ne
veut pas se priver des opportunités qui
existent en asie je rappelle que le
royaume uni est un pays qui a une très
longue tradition de du commerce à
l'international dans le secteur un peu
dans tous les sens clos ça remonte des
cercles et des et des siècles et donc à
il s'agit aussi de renouer avec cette
liberté de change
c'est ça votre centre dans la stratégie
du du plan après brique site absolument
absolument le un des arguments en faveur
du bric site était précisément que le
fait de sortir de l'union européenne
d'un aura beaucoup plus de liberté à au
royaume uni de nouer des liens avec
d'autres d'autres pays
pourquoi parce que un moment états
membres de l'union européenne
renonce à négocier des traités de libre
échange avec des pays tiers et toute la
compétence en ce domaine se trouve à
bruxelles
exclusivement à l'exclusion des états
membres donc le royaume uni n'étant plus
en état membre n'est pas richard
complètement à cette centralisation et a
pris ce qu'il s'agit de un seul pays de
loire muni n'ont pas de 27 ou 28 en
principe il doit être plus facile de
négocier des contrats à ddd traiter
parce que c'est un pur l'union
européenne des 27 vous avez les intérêts
de 26 à m art monique chaque fois qu'il
s'agit de faire un traité avec les états
unis ou le canada
et ça c'est toujours très compliqué la
dernière question c'est qu'il ya
certains pays qui étaient pessimistes
dans leurs relations futures après le
break site
certaines entreprises japonaises
justement ont émis un certain doute
on peut citer par exemple toyota ou
nissan quelles sont leurs positions
aujourd'hui maintenant que ça il ya le
break cité était est acté je pense que
ces entreprises sont toujours en
position d'attenté
il y a eu un article qui a fait pas mal
de bruit dans le financial times la
semaine dernière disant que nissan
s'apprête peut être à se concentrer sur
le marché britannique et a relevé sa
part de marché de 5 à 20 % à ou dépens
de volkswagen et de fortes qui
produisent sur le continent et exporte
vers le royaume uni
nissan a dit qu'il la suite à cet
article qu aucune décision n'avait été
prise
il est clair que ces deux grosses
entreprises souhaitent que les lélés les
chaînes de production
d'approvisionnement ne soit pas
perturbée entre le royaume-uni et le
continent ils sont obligés d'attendre de
voir quel traité sera négociée entre
leur mini le continent qu'ils sont dans
une position d'attenté
mais je répète il ya dans le domaine des
finances nommé rock est une grosse
entreprise financière japonaise qui est
très engagée à londres elle le restera
nika que j'ai déjà cité restera
actionnaire de dufner total serait
certainement et donc
japon économique ne va pas se dégage des
engagés du roi munich plutôt le
contraire à mon avis très bien en tout
cas merci beaucoup monsieur paul comme
ça d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes président du
parti conservateur à paris